oblivion another film this year about
Earth sucking balls this film is [ __ ]
great I loved it in a lot of weights
let's start off with that hunky dunky
man Tom Cruise well I've been saying
this about a lot of actors lately and I
would also suck this guy's dick look the
dudes buff but he's an intense [ __ ]
actor I don't care how many people hate
on him the dude [ __ ] rocks Morgan
Freeman's also in it that's about it the
redhead who plays tom cruise's partner /
girlfriend she does a really good job
too she kinda has we're teeth though the
direction from joseph kosinski cone
quinn ski karinski her the [ __ ] you
pronounce it is excellent way better
than tron legacy he strikes the perfect
tone really knows how to work well with
a cinematographer the editing is
excellent this score moves you it's
[ __ ] awesome the visual effects are
the most impressive thing about this
movie they're absolutely astounding 100%
believable I would have sex with those
visual effects oh that rhymed yes there
are some confusing plot points here and
there I was a little bit lost at times
but for the most part I was just very
much captivated by the whole thing even
when I was confused I was still
entertained one of the things I really
admire about this movie is that it just
unfolds before you none of its
predictable it's a great thrill ride to
watch and it has a lot of story to it
it's not as action packed as one might
expect but it's still one hell of a ride
let me get straight to the point here
all at all i gotta say oblivion got it
right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review please go ahead and go to that
comment box and tell me your points
about oblivion below and if you want to
see more in-depth review of oblivion go
ahead and check out my show that I do
with my buddy Jerry called reasons to
see where we give you reasons to see and
not to see oblivion the last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time a new review is out please go ahead
and subscribe to my channel on the link
right there